hello friends and welcome back to rapid  fire language learning today we're  exploring the question  how to not mix up two languages  now mixing up languages is in fact  inevitable  when it comes to language learning and  the more similar these languages are  the more interference is going to happen  but there are things that you can do  in order to minimize this interference  my piece of advice in this regard is  that if you're learning two languages at  the same time or if you know  these two languages maybe you know one  well and you're learning another one  make sure that you practice these  languages  both every single day maybe one language  is more dominant in your life and you  get to use it more often  but do not forget to spend even five  minutes  with the other language every day  because this way you're telling your  brain that that language actually those  two languages  are both important that's it for today  over  and out